hey there everybody I'm Walter burn a Z
AK and this is top 5 with the premiere
of the very first live-action Justice
League movie days away now is a great
time to go back and relive one of the
best superhero cartoon series ever the
DCA use justice league this show was a
DC fans dream come true back in the
early 2000s debuting in 2001 justice
league continues the continuity of Bruce
Tim's Batman the Animated Series and
Superman the animated series with the
universe already established major
heroes previously unseen were introduced
and united under the Justice League
banner the show was an instant hit and
the beginning of the culmination of the
DC Animated universe as we knew it
almost every episode was attached to a
multi-part er which gave the writers an
opportunity to create longer and deeper
stories after a Twitter poll I put up
you guys voted to give Justice League
Unlimited its own separate countdown
thus those episodes will not be on this
list
be on the lookout for that video next
year it's time for justice let's get
into the countdown these are the top 5
best episodes of Justice League number 5
in justice for all from season 1 this
episode centers around Lex Luthor
forming the injustice gang and shows off
just how sly Batman really is Lex Luthor
is finally captured by the Justice
League but as he attempted to evade them
he discovers he has a terminal medical
condition due to his overexposure to
kryptonite in jail
Lex teams up with the ultra Humanite to
escape and eventually recruits shade
Copperhead star sapphire Solomon Grundy
Cheeta and later the Joker to form the
injustice gang their sole purpose
destroy the Justice League at any cost
with Lex more desperate and dangerous
than ever
things look grim for the league when
Batman is captured this was the first
time on the show we got to see a
villainous counter group to the Justice
League they matched up decently well to
our heroes and this stuff with Lex is
pretty good it sets up his arc for the
rest of the show
the real
standout of this episode though is
Batman and his storyline that venom
almost killed you so so you're staying
here you're a valued member of this team
and we're only trying to I'm taking the
shuttle unless you want to try and stop
me no Batman has a bit of an inferiority
complex here this leads him to getting
captured and sexy time with cheetah too
much curiosity can be dangerous maybe I
like danger do you try me
anyway it's always great to hear this
[Music]
No maybe it was the Joker's appearance
but this episode has always stood out in
my memory when thinking of the best
Justice League episodes on the rewatch
it didn't disappoint and I had those
flames out before the firemen even
stepped off their trucks that's fast
fastest man alive which might explain
why you can't get a date yeah hey number
four a better world
from season two a lot happened in this
episode it wasn't just your
run-of-the-mill doppelganger story and
an alternate earth a familiar team of
Heroes ruled their world these are the
Justice Lords composed of Superman
Batman Wonder Woman Green Lantern
Hawkgirl and the Martian Manhunter there
earth is free of crime but the way they
achieved that was through setting aside
their morals and ruling through
authoritarian fear it's discovered that
justice Lord Batman has created an
interdimensional gateway into the
universe of the Justice League
seeing this version of their selves as
they used to be gives them the idea to
help the League by taking over and
ruling their earth as well they capture
the league and begin taking control
while our original heroes are kept
locked in cells until the lords have
accomplished their mission on top of all
that's happening with the league and the
Lord's doomsday shows up here what do
you want
same as you I imagine power control but
I had to see the bestest planet had to
offer I am NOT impressed and he talks
what a weird choice the Superman
doomsday fight here has a few classic
moments from their fight in the comics
but it does feel a bit shoehorned in
although he does come back in unlimited
what if Superman crossed the line that
question has been asked a lot in recent
years perhaps most prominently in the
injustice video games this story
showcases just one possible scenario
being a hero was too important to you
you're as much responsible for this as I
am so go ahead fix it somehow put me on
trial lock me up but I'll be
I did love being a hero but if this is
where it leads I'm done with it
what pushed the justice Lords over the
edge was the death of their flash so
whenever one of them interacts with the
league's flash it's very interesting I
don't want to hear it believe me the
last thing we want is to lose another
another what
[Music]
once again Batman is a very strong part
of this story and we get him in stereo
you grabbed power and with that power
we've made a world where no
eight-year-old boy will ever lose his
parents because of some punk with a gun
we also get a dark little tease from Lex
that matches something that happened on
the Justice Lords earth where do you go
from here back to running LexCorp oh the
business world doesn't seem as
challenging as it used to and there's no
poetry in it either I have been giving
some thought to politics
number three hereafter from season two
this was a very well done story that's
almost interchangeable with what's
coming up at number two some of
Superman's greatest enemies form a pact
to destroy the Man of Steel for good in
a huge battle in Metropolis the Toyman
is blasting things away with a giant
disintegrator ray it eventually hits
Superman leaving no trace of him left
the entire world thinks he's dead and
they mourn him accordingly the greatest
hero Earth has ever known is gone and
everyone he's ever associated himself
with shows up to pay their respects
however the truth behind Superman's
shocking death is more than meets the
eye just in case you haven't seen this
episode yet I'd highly suggest it watch
it first then come back I'm gonna have
to get into some spoilers part 1 covers
the death of Superman very well they
sell it perfectly the other leaguers
appropriately feel his loss how many
battles did we win simply because he was
there yeah I used to be able to goof
around so much because I knew Superman
had my back now all I've got is his
example and that's gonna have to be
enough even some of Superman's enemies
come to pay their respects are you happy
now isn't this what you've always wanted
I hate you
[Music]
to listen to the best moment from his
funeral comes as his friends walk his
coffin down a big Avenue in Metropolis
the theme blares and we're really
invested in what's happening
[Music]
even though he's not convinced Superman
is dead Batman says a few touching words
about his longtime friend I've got some
things to say I should have said them
when you were here but despite our
differences I have nothing but respect
for you I hope you knew no you showed me
that justice doesn't always have to come
from the darkness part two is completely
different we see that Superman is alive
the beam that was used to supposedly
destroy him actually sent him thousands
of years into the future so far into the
future that Earth's Sun has now turned
red and he doesn't have his powers from
here on out it's survivalist Superman
roughing it on his own it's seriously
great stuff he makes his own sword and I
love it
[Music]
the only human left alive by his own
doing is the immortal Vandal Savage your
funeral was lovely it was on all the
networks he used to have the DVD I'm
glad you enjoyed it as a matter of fact
I did but I've had 30,000 years to
reconsider savage now regrets what he
did and tries to help Superman return to
the Past to stop his younger self from
eradicating the human race
they fight giant cockroach creatures
together and it's unexpectedly amazing
who actually have sympathy for the
villainous Savage and seeing these two
work together was great this episode is
very unique with two very different
parts even if you aren't a traditional
Superman fan you might get some
enjoyment out of seeing him use his wits
instead of his powers to survive only
two episodes top this one number two
legends from season one all right this
episode is just awesome Superman Batman
and Wonder Woman aren't even really in
it during a fight with a giant robot
controlled by Lex Luthor the Justice
League D powers the massive mechanical
menace but as it begins to topple
Hawkgirl Green Lantern and Martian
Manhunter are put directly in harm's way
the flash tries to save them by keeping
the robot airborne but he ends up
running so fast that he transports
himself and anyone nearby into an
alternate dimension the league is
surprised to see that they've arrived in
seaboard city an idyllic town
reminiscent of 1950s America they find
out that another superhero team inhabits
the city called the Justice guild the
guild is made up of the Green Guardsman
Tom turbine the streak black siren and
cat man after an initial spat the guild
agrees to help the league find their way
home this episode is also a favorite of
the showrunners behind it originally
they wanted to use the JSA in the story
but were turned down by DC Comics
although it's pretty obvious who's
supposed to be who this episode is full
of classic Golden Age fun
[Music]
[Applause]
you've got to be kidding only they would
commit such a heinous act and on a
Sunday you're a credit to your people
son
thanks yeah that's in there too another
very cool aspect of this story is that
the justice guild where comic-book
heroes and the Justice League's earth
John Stuart even grew up idolizing that
so it's really cathartic to see him get
to live out his childhood dreams with
his heroes however something is
noticeably strange with this whole
situation and as things get weirder it
makes the episode that much more
interesting if you've never seen this
one it's an essential installment of the
show if you have give it a rewatch you
won't regret like basically all the DCAU
shows quality was something we could
really count on with Justice League that
being said here are the episodes that
just missed out on the top 5 as
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Justice League
episode is star-crossed from season two
honestly how could it be anything else
spoilers ahead folks thanagarians invade
earth as Hawkgirl is revealed as being a
spy for her people all along the
thanagarians claim they are protecting
the earth from their mortal enemies the
gordanians but their leader wrote alak
later confesses to Hawkgirl
that isn't exactly the case Hawkgirl
also makes it known that she was engaged
to CRO the entire time leaving a
recently started relationship with Jon
Stewart in question as the league digs
deeper into the thanagarians presence on
earth they must do everything possible
to discover the invaders real intentions
no matter what this was a massive
three-parter and inappropriate end to
this version of the show the heartbeat
of this finale is the love triangle
between Green Lantern Hawkgirl and Kroll
talaq it's an emotionally gripping story
that we had been following 2/3 of for a
long time at that point
Jon there were so many times I wanted to
but this was a military mission I'd
sworn an oath of secrecy and I couldn't
tell anyone
sorry but not even you you're a soldier
I think you'd understand hawkgirl's
betrayal not only affected her
relationship with Green Lantern it
changed everything moving forward about
the show this is arguably the most
substantial event in the history of the
DCAU whose side are you really on
[Music]
part two has any secret identities among
the group put aside as the league tries
to regroup at Wayne Manor what about the
whole secret identity thing I mean I
trust you guys but I'm not sure I'm
ready to Wally West Clark Kent
Bruce Wayne showoff
in addition to Batman nearly sacrificing
himself to destroy the thanagarian
stronghold on earth GL and Hawkman I
mean guy Hawk guy fight in a passion
fueled finale over the fate of the earth
and hot girls heart this won't be like
the last time you do something that
belonged to me anything I took was
freely off maybe you should take better
care of your stuff any last words
[Music]
my grandma and this ending is absolutely
heartbreaking an undeniably powerful
moment that closed out the show
[Music]
I love you John I never lied about that
there's a new Justice League cartoon in
town that debuted late last year to
check out my thoughts on Justice League
action and how it stacks up to the
classic series head on over to my
personal channel where a new video just
went up on the subject I want to hear
what you guys think what is your
favorite Justice League episode why do
you want me to cover next on the show
leave a comment and let me know to stay
in touch like my Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome Walter B and
follow along on Twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future come back next week for a new
episode of top 5
[Music]
you